on en vient aux élections européennes
françois bayrou président du modem est
notre invité ce soir est justement avec
daniel sporty louis m'a dit diawara
voyons comment ils mènent campagne mais
pour quelle élection au fait celle ci ou
celle de 2012
les librairies un passage obligé pour
françois bayrou en campagne pour les
européennes
je suis bon jour inclut son livre abus
de pouvoir fait un tabac est ici dans la
ville de troyes comme ailleurs la file
d'attenté sur le salon jusqu'à la maison
de la presse nous allons accueillir
désolé de vous le faire envahir le
peuple désolé pas tant que ça car les
lecteurs sont aussi des électeurs et
pendant la séance de dédicaces les
encouragements pleuvent bon jacqueline
et jean chez pas qu'ils aient saison
nous parle vous avez le soutien de toute
la famille bien ça me fait plaisir
et donc probablement plus à les faire 15
%
européenne 13 14 rien dans les sondages
il est toujours le troisième homme comme
à l'époque de l'élection présidentielle
la jeunesse a besoin du groupe biesse je
pense qu'en 2007 c'était le tour de
chauffe et qu'on en 2012 quand vous avez
gagné
est-ce que vous avez la positive de
l'intelligence du coeur et comme en 2007
françois bayrou inquiète les partis
politiques dont ils grignotent
l'électorat c'est un intrus s'est
l'agneau parmi les loups l'huile à la
gauche et la droite contre lui jean
françois cadet partie non violent lassé
d'attendre françois bayrou jean françois
kahn s'est réfugié dans un café tête de
liste modem dans le grand est
il défend bayrou qui est accusé de se
tromper de campagne et de ne penser qu'à
2012 et il n'est pas candidat aux
élections européennes
pourquoi ils feraient quoi d'ailleurs ça
me dérange la nuit ici faisait une
campagne européenne j'irai bientôt de
quoi tu te mêles lui vers leader
national éventuellement sera opposé à
sarkozy qui oppose son modèle chic
sarkozy chacun sa position jusqu'à son
boulot chacun son boulot même si à
l'occasion françois bayrou joue les
techniciens de régime non d'une réunion
publique dans la marne et la cible c'est
l'isola sarkozy et ses amis
accusé de privilégier la loi du plus
fort la loi de l'argent